okay and if you haven't figured out your
Halloween costume yet oh don't worry
you're in luck we've got you covered
this morning we've got Candace Charles
live this morning over at star costume
over on Charleston testing the best
there is Candace you seem to have dialed
up the superhero quotient this morning
good morning to you
lady power has step
ped to the
actual Supply building just kidding guys
it's me Candace but oh they got you
covered with all the great costumes they
have here some you can make yourself
some that are already packaged up and
the prices are pretty good honestly you
can come down here and try it out all
out yourself that's what's great about
having a local shop you guys can come to
and check out and I'm joined by Jared
salts the manager who will be here
throughout the day to help you out tell
me tell people a little bit about what I
got on right now and how much this cost
so this is our lady power she's about 65
but I have ones that will range about 50
all the way up to about 350 when you get
to the higher range they're going to be
more of a corseted top so a little bit
more tight fitting to the body okay cool
cool and there are a lot of different
options we saw some clowns here we
showed you guys a little bit of scary
stuff earlier today tell us what are the
popular costumes what's been selling out
and whether the price is in general here
so it's really our traditional costume
so you're talking your with your witches
your Wizards your superheroes your
occupations military your traditional
Halloween costumes okay and what do you
think is like the average price
um average price is probably going to a
range within that 65 to 85 dollar range
is probably the sweet spot for most
costumes cool cool and you know the cool
thing is he put a little bit of red
lipstick on me guys yes he's here right
now they
for you as far as makeup you can really
get the blood going some teeth and
everything tell us a little bit about
these accessories you guys have going on
so we provide a professional themed
makeup uh here in the valley so we help
anybody who's doing Productions anything
from school plays all the way up to
Major Productions on the Strip so we
want to make sure we cover everything
that they may need or require to do what
they need to for whatever show or
broadcast that is awesome thank you so
much Jared I appreciate it as he
mentioned I mean they help people 24
days 24 days throughout the year you
guys it's still early coffee's not gonna
get in but nonetheless you can come down
here to the store off of Charleston from
10 a.m to 8pm I got you covered with all
those details on our website newsnow.com
for now live from star costume and
Theatrical Supply I'm Candace Charles or
lady Power 8 news now it looked great I
love it that's a cool costume it's a
sharp costume yeah incredible stuff
Charleston and Valley View because
Charleston's a Long Street right yeah